هناك غموض منذ ايام عما يدل في سوليدار
عندما اعلنت مجموعه فاجنر لاستيلاء عليها
النفت القوات الاوكرانيه وبثت سوبر مسجله
من داخل المدينه لكنها اعترفت بان قوات
باتنه وتتقدم في المنطقه الشرقيه والمنطقه
الشماليه وهذا الغموض ما زال دائما الا
هذا الصباح من تم الاعلان على قناه
تليجرام تابعه للجيش الاوكراني بان القوات
الروسيه وخصوصا والقوات الروسيه والقوات
المقاتله معها اي مجموعه فهد ناصر سيطره
على اخر جزء من المنطقه همم من المنطقه
الصناعيه في غرب المدينه وهما يعني دون
الاعترافيه لا تعترف اوكرانيا بسقوط مدنها
تحت الاحتلال الروسي كما تسميه ولكن هو
اعلان ضمني ان ج- كبيره ما سميت بالمنطقه
الاداريه والصناعيه الغربيه هي تحت سيطره
تحت الاحتلال الروسي بحسب تعبير عن مدينه
مهمه يحتاجها الجيش الروسي بدايه جغرافيا
واستراتي كان اثنا عشر كيلومتر الى الشمال
الشرقي من مدينه بخمود قد تكون محور جديد
للذهاب الى بخموت ومحاوله اسقاطها من
المنطقه الشماليه استراتيجيا هي به ضاب
عاليه بامكانهم
بامكانهم قطع خطوط الامداد الاخرانيه في
الدخل الاوكراني على غرب على غرب المدينه
على طول الطريقه المحاديه لدروج كيف كان
لمدينه محمود ولكنها اقتصاديه
ومهمه وبالاخير هي ايضا رمزيه مهمه
بالنسبه الي روسيا